c'est depuis le foyer de l'enfance
Robert Carpentier à Versailles que le
Conseil Général des yelines a présenté
son plan de protection a fait un état
des lieux c'était cet après-midi la
protection de l'enfant c'est une
compétence une compétence obligatoire du
Conseil Général du desivlin vous vous en
occupez parce que c'est une obligation
mais est-ce que ça veut dire pour autant
que vous y mettez les moyens alors
évidemment en tant que compétence
obligatoire une de nos compétences
obligatoires comme tous les conseils
généraux
nous devons mettre les moyens
nécessaires pour cette cette compétence
il faut savoir que chaque année le
Conseil Général dépense 80 millions
d'euros dans le domaine de la protection
de l'enfance et 80 millions d'euros sont
principalement utilisés pour payer les
places d'hébergement des enfants que ce
soit dans un hébergement d'urgence comme
on a nous au niveau du du conseil
général directement géré par le Conseil
général ou alors l'hébergement dans les
familles d'accueil ou dans des
associations dans tous les secteurs
associatifs alors qu'englobe la
protection de l'enfance quelles sont les
réalités qui se cachent derrière alors
la protection de l'enfance c'est à
chaque fois que un enfant peut être en
difficulté en danger euh que ce soit
danger dans sa sa sa santé sa moralité
son intégrité euh le il peut être
question par le juge la plupart du temps
de retirer l'enfant de de sa famille
pour le mettre à l'écart et donc en fait
on peut avoir des des dangers qui sont
des dangers physique hein parfit des
dangers vraiment importants avec des
enfants maltraités mais également des
maltraitances de type psychique qui
peuvent psychologiques qui peuvent aussi
arriver donc c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à cerner et là tout le les
acteurs du domaine de l'enfants sont
concernés pour éventuellement signaler
ce type de difficulté en fait que soit
l'éducation nationale les médecins les
hôpitaux les crèches tous ceux qui ont
un lien avec les les enfants ont le
devoir c'est marqué dans la loi ont le
devoir de prévenir de signaler ces
difficultés sur une cellule en fait
composée spécialement dans chaque
département est-ce qu'il y a des cas qui
sont de plus en plus nombreux est-ce que
les les cas sont de plus en plus souvent
signalés justement maintenant que ça
devient de plus en plus connu qu'on en
parle de plus en plus alors dans le
département des ivelines on a pas une
augmentation importante du nombre de cas
parce qu'on est on a un nombre d'enfants
chaque année de l'ordre de 2000 on a
2120 enfants par exemple au 31 décembre
2012 qui était suivi par nos services et
on est à une centaine près en fait 2100
2000 2200 donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas très différent d'une sur
l'autre donc on peut pas dire que soit
la situation économique soit le fait que
c'est davantage médiatisé nous amène
plus de plus d'enfants dans le
département des ivelines enfin plus de
situations à être connu en tout cas vous
parliez des différentes structures il y
a Cell de Versailles vous étiez cet
après-midi on peut peut-être s'arrêter
justement sur ce foyer mise adolescents
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance SS
sont hébergés oui alors pas que des
adolescents puisque le la protection de
l'enfance pour le département les
établissement géré directement par le
Département c'est 80 places donc c'est
pas un nombre important mais c'est 80
places d'urgence c'està qu'on est
capable d'accueillir un enfant euh
quasiment dans le dans dans l'heure qui
vient donc à partir du moment où on est
saisi par le juge donc là c'est c'est
une chose importante et on accueille les
enfants ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
que les enfants sont accueillis de
quelques jours d'existence donc on
reçoit des nouveaux nés jusqu'à 18 ans
il reste combien de temps il reste
combien de temps dans ces foyers alors
il il reste le normalement en fait le le
foyer est là pour accueillir euh puis
euh observer on observe le le les
enfants en fait on travaille avec eux et
ensuite on les on les oriente donc en
fait c'est les les établissements dont
j'ai la la la charge en tant que
conseiller général sont des
établissements dans lesquels les enfants
restent au maximum 4 mois et ensuite ils
retournent avec leur famille ça veut
dire que la situation s'est
amélioréement alors pas forcément en
fait on aimerait qu'il puisse retourner
avec leur famille on a à peu près
globalement sur le département des
ivelines un/ers des enfants qui
retournent chez leur famille dans leur
famille à l'issue de cette période là le
reste/ REST et le reste des 2/ers en
fait sont ensuite placés soit dans les
familles en fait par les des dans les
assistants familiaux donc dans les
familles d'accueil euh on a environ 200
familles d'accueil qui qui travaillent
le département des iveline localisé dans
le département mais éventuellement
ailleurs dans d'autres départements et
également dans le secteur associatif qui
est un secteur qui accueille aussi
beaucoup de d'enfants ce qu'on appelle
les mex les maisons éducatives à
caractère social nous allons écouter à
présent l'une des adolescentes justement
qui est éébergé actuellement dans ce
foyer de de Versailles que nous avons
rencontré cet après-midi elle la 15 ans
et demi Chloé on l'écoute
qui a demandé à ce que tu sois placé ici
pour quelques mois mon
père comment tu l'as pris quand il l'as
demandé ton àce que tu viennes ici B dé
il me l'avait pas dit que c'était lui il
me l'a dit il y a pas longtemps après je
me suis dit bah que c'était mieux comme
ça voilà pourquoi c'est mieux comme ça
bah parce que là je sors pas donc je
fais pas de bêtis je me mets pas en
danger je cherche un travail pour
l'année prochaine ce que je faisais pas
quand j'étais chez moi et que j'allais
plus à l'école est-ce que tu dirais que
ce ce cet accueil ici ce foyer ça t'a un
peu sauvé ou en tout cas aidé changer
peut-être de cap euh bah oui ça m'a aidé
parce que si je serais resté chez moi
j'aurais pas avancé j'aurais sûrement
pas trouvé de travail pour l'année
prochaine j'aurais continué mes bêtises
alors que là bah non ça a changé grâce
au travail des éducateurs des fois parce
qu'on doit se coucher à 22h30 donc ça
fait bizarre par rapport à chez nous
enfin par rapport à chez moi plutôt
parce que moi je me couchais vers 5h ou
6h du matin donc ça fait bizarre mais
sinon ça va voilà VO c'estes jeunes qui
qui réapprennent à avoir une vie somme
toutes normal et non plus à se coucher
par exemple à 6h du matin comme dans le
cas de de Chloé par exemple là pour
Chloé justement ce sont ses parents qui
ont décidé de la placer parce que ils
avaient du mal avec elle tout simplement
ils n'arrivaient plus à à gérer leur
enfant oui c'est on a à peu près 20 %
des cas des enfants qui nous sont
confiés qui sont confiés par leurs
parents directement donc on est en
dehors de toute décision judiciaire donc
c'est aussi une bonne chose on montre
bien ça montre bien le la limite de des
familles parfois arriver à gérer leur
leurs enfants élever un enfant c'est
extrêmement difficile donc il faut
pouvoir de temps en temps se dire je ne
suis plus en mesure de le faire c'est
pas forcément évident justement pour les
parents aussi de de reconnaître leurs
propres limite dans des cas où ça
devient vraiment très compliqué de par
l'environnement de par les limites tout
simplement aussi qu'onon peut avoir dans
les échanges avec ses enfants ou parfois
c'est difficile oui c'est pas c'est pas
si simple parce que c'est reconnaître
son échec enfin quel en quelque part
quelque sorte un échec je veux pas dire
que c'est forcément un échec grave ça
peut être absolument c'est le donc
l'échec n'importe quelle famille pe
connaîre un échec avec un enfant même
une famille nombreuse on peut avoir tous
les enfants qui fonctionnent bien et
puis un qui qui qui qui a des
difficultés donc il faut c'est bien que
le département puisse être en mesure de
proposer des choses euh qui euh je veux
pas dire qui remettent l'enfant dans le
dans le droit chemin parce que c'est pas
ça l'objectif mais qui permet de de
renouer le lien de l'enfant avec avec sa
famille et une chose importante c'est
que la loi stipule le Code civil hein
stipule que il est important de pouvoir
garder l'enfant au maximum dans son
milieu familial donc là quand c'est la
famille qui demande évidemment c'est
c'est le mieux mais lorsqu'on passe sur
le côté judiciaire et bien il y a un
certain nombre de mesurees où on peut
avec le juge continuer à garder l'enfant
dans sa famille pour continuer à
accompagner alors on parlait du foyer de
versaill des jeunes qui sont hébergés il
y aura une évolution vous l'avez dit cet
après-midi lors de la présentation de de
ce plan de protection de l'enfance du du
département vous allez fermer la
structure de Versailles mais pour vous
redéployer à travers le département en
fait oui alors ce redéploiement a déjà
commencé c'estàd que la structure de
Versailles qui se trouve juste à la
limite de versaill du reflet d'ailleurs
euh existe c'est la structure historique
euh et depuis 2 ans on a ouvert une
structure OPEC euh donc on a euh
pratiquement 48 enfants et euh d'ici 2
ans on aura deux autres structures qui
seront créées dans le la ville de
montelajoli euh et donc ils sont en
cours le chantier est en train de de
s'installer donc pour ces deux
structures qui permettra d'augmenter un
petit peu la capacité d'accueil
notamment vis-à-vis des adolescents
puisque pour l'instant on a ouvert h
places d'accueil d'adolescents et il y
en aura euh 26 euh sur euh sur Montel
jolie aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
répondre à toutes les demandes alors on
répond de toute façon à toutes les
demandes ça c'est une chose qui est
importante à savoir même si on peut pas
répondre directement avec notre euh
maison de l'enfance on trouvera de toute
façon une solution parce que lorsque le
juge nous dit il faut placer cet enfant
dans l'heure l'enfant sera placé dans
l'heure on trouvera une solution on a
toujours des personnes d'astreintes qui
trouverons une solution que soit dans
notre notre foyer ou euh ou dans un
système associatif mais en tout cas tout
cas on aura toujours une solution et
l'enfant sera de toute façon suivie par
nos services merci Olivier lebrin pour
cette présentation de ce dispositif de
protection de l'enfance conseiller
général UMP des ivelines par ailleurs
maire de viroflet d'ailleurs vous serez
candidat à un nouveau mandat je profité
de l'occasion puisque vous êtes présent
sur le plateau c'est une bonne question
pour l' jeai encore rien dit pour
l'instant euh vous pouvez le dire ce
soir si vous le souhaitez je pense que
j'ai encore un certain nombre de de
choses à faire je pense à à viroffl en
tout cas bah c'est un choix que je ferai
avec ma famille parce que c'est aussi un
c'est très contraignant pour pour la
famille donc c'est un choix qui devrait
être partagé mais je j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et et si les
acteurs ve veulent bien de moi ben
peut-être que on on continuera mais tout
cas vous vous ne fermez pas la porte
hein on a bien on a bien entendu he et
je pense que VO en tout cas je trouve
encore beaucoup
d'intérêt personnel et dans dans ce
travail qui est un travail au quotidien
qui est qui est passionnant avec les les
les habitants et et nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler bien évidemment
vous le savez TVfil lanc c'est ce
nouveau rendez-vous politique chaque
mois municipal 2014 vous pouvez revoir
d'ailleurs le numéro du mois de mars sur
notre site Internet et le prochain
numéro en avril ce sera le 13 avril